and a list of events taking place this
weekend in memoriam of 9 11. last night
we mentioned the stair climb taking
place at the strat that is tomorrow
morning at 8 30 on sunday las vegas fire
and rescue will hold a bell toll that's
at 6 45 a.m after the bell ringing a u.s
flag that once flew over the world trade
center will be raised to half staff over
the station this will be at fire station
five near valley view in charleston
at 9 11 a.m the public is invited to the
clark county government center downtown
for the never forget 9 11 ceremony a
firefighter who survived the attack will
be speaking there will also be a flyover
by nellis air force jet during the
singing of the national anthem the
professional firefighters of nevada will
host a procession at the fremont
experience at 7 p.m first responders
leading a march concluding with a toast
at hogs and heifers
at a special ceremony at palo verde high
school this morning their air force
junior rotc held a ceremony in
remembrance of the victims of 9 11. they
also honored one of their own barbara
edwards a teacher who worked there was
on board american airlines flight 77
that crashed into the pentagon the
annual event passes on the significance
of 9 11 to our younger generations